foreign
Eileen what's up Eileen how we doing hi
how are you partying how are you
I'm actually taking my lunch but um
that's so funny that you said Come On
Eileen you're uh
um when I was a kid now you got to
remember my name rhymes with like a
terrible lunch meat right so
um I was John baloney and we had a
friend like in our little gang named
Eileen and we used to call her I leaned
over and we used to say is your friend
Ben coming over and I always thought
that was hilarious I leaned over and
bend over so um same team so what's up
dude
hi
um so I like wrote I know I know so I
wrote down my question because I knew
that I was just gonna like go rambling
on so my question is go for it
um I'm afraid so okay I'm afraid my
daughters will follow my footsteps and
become a teen mom like I was and I know
you often say like you know there you
have an alarm system well my alarms are
like blaring right now
um I have a 14 and 13 year old right now
but
um I have five I have five kids four of
them girls
um
yes wow okay I know I know
um it's a lot in that house
yeah yeah a lot and then uh my boy
doesn't have any say pretty much but are
you married
um I just got divorced okay all right
yeah but
um yeah my alarms are like you know just
blaring and I've become very controlling
um with my older ones I have more
patience with the younger ones but with
my 14 and 13 year old I am so
controlling to the point that the other
day my daughter
um she said mom you're literally making
me feel like I'm a up and I'm like
that's not my intention and
um I often I'm gonna get emotional
because yeah it's all right it's all
right go for it
I feel like
I'm still controlling because I want
I don't want this life that I mean I I
think I have a good life now you know
but I don't want them to go through the
struggles that I did
um and I often my anxiety kicks in and I
often portray that as anger when I'm
talking to them when I'm trying to walk
them through a life situation or
um
so I I like I play this in my head like
maybe if my parents just you know
told me hey just keep playing sports or
you know like do this club in high
school or something you know and so I've
been doing that with my girls that's not
it
tell me about your um tell me about your
divorce
um so
so
um I met him when I was uh 19. and that
yeah I was 19 but my three my three
older kiddos they're from my high school
not so sweetheart I like to say okay
um and uh I spent pretty much all my 20s
um in this relationship and it's funny
how like how old reunion your first kid
I was 16. 16. okay
16 and I had my so 16 17 and 19. okay
and that's with the high school
boyfriend yeah okay all right and so is
that dude still in the picture
no he never really was
um until after my son was born you know
I just I I had this picture like I want
a family I want this to work out but he
was always cheating on me and
um so I you know I finished high school
did some college and
um you know now I'm here but then I met
you know my ex my ex-husband
um
and uh we ended up getting married and
we had two more kids
um and he pretty much is Raising he's
raising all the kiddos
um I think we have a better relationship
now than we did as we were married
um why is that
um
he was uh very jealous I'm like a very
like
suddenly I talk to everybody I just you
know I I'm a happy person and he was
he he had a lot of trauma okay okay we
eat a lot of trauma and um he couldn't
understand how
you know he could be loved when he just
grew up in a house where there was no
love at all
um and I try to love him and can you
understand that
yeah I understand it now no no no no can
you understand being loved
to be honest Dr
Unk I don't think you can I don't think
you can
so let me let me
like as I'm listening to you talk yes
you've got teenage girls they are
entering into the season when you
discovered your sexuality guys started
giving you attention and that whole
thing went sideways you had a baby at
16. that's a that's a that's a huge uh I
don't know if it's called traumatizing
but it's a that's a kid having a kid
right that's a huge thing
yeah and were your parents involved at
all
[Music]
it's getting so is my mom and they both
came from really big families where my
grandma also had her kid at like 15 you
know sure um it wasn't a weird you
weren't a terrible human kind of thing
right right right you know okay so
um so it just was what it was but but
here's what I want to say like
um
it's right for your body to be trying to
get your attention right it went through
a lot
16 years old is tough that's really hard
even with your it's a full support of
your family that's hard and then another
one is 17.
I'm in my 40s and I have two kids and I
don't know what day it is
when I was 17 17 God Almighty and then
you had a third like so
and then you the dad never shows up
and he's just a bum an absolute bum
and you have these visions and these
dreams of what love is going to look
like and what family is going to look
like and not only that but you have the
first generation pressure of you're
gonna make it you're gonna do all these
things that we didn't get to do that's
why we're here right and you have all
this pressure all this stuff and then
you find somebody that says I do
and he's got his own trauma passed and
he's trying to raise five kids and you
all are trying to raise five kids
what it sounds like to me is you've got
a body that has been screaming at you
for years that honey we are not safe
we're not safe we're not connected we
are one or two decisions away from not
having food on the table
and first first baby daddy like
he didn't want to be around no this guy
doesn't want to be around like
your body's trying to get your attention
and so yeah we gotta deal with the high
school kids I mean we got to deal with
that that's that's gonna come and I've
got some some thoughts about that
the greatest gift you can give your
daughters
is for you
to break what I would say is a
generational curse
and that is I'm going to take care of
Mom and make sure Mom is well and Mom is
whole
I promise you with all my heart
your parents telling you to go play
softball or to be on the track team
would not have made you feel more loved
it wouldn't have
and you know that too right
yeah
and so how long how long have you been
divorced
um
well we've been separated for two years
and divorced for one
so are the girls in the boy are they
going back and forth how they were how
y'all working that out
um so so
um during summer they uh the girls don't
usually go over there anymore
um because they rather hang out with
their friends
there's times where they do go hang out
with you know they call him dad
um but the three younger ones they're
there Tuesdays and like Wednesdays
overnight
um and then I get them the rest of the
week and you know because I I deliver my
also my schedule is kind of wonky
um
but uh and you know I have been
um like you said taking care of Mom so I
have been
um you know seeing a therapist and my my
me and my two older girls actually see
the same therapist we I feel like
there's some trauma there maybe like me
growing up because you said you know a
kid raising a kid yeah yeah it's just
gonna be hard no matter what yeah yeah
how's that going
um it's cool really good um I actually
saw her yesterday
um and she she said
she said I'm my oldest
so she said your oldest can come back
whenever she feels like she wants to
because I think she's she's done she's
been doing great
um so whenever that pops up you know
I'll send it back but an important part
about the counseling is
it gives you tools
here's what I think I think between you
especially your tools and we you and I
could talk for probably six hours on all
the all the pieces to this but let's
focus on on the two uh oldest girls
because that's that's the main reason
why I call
um
what those girls need more than anything
is a direct line connection with their
mom
and this sounds like some big like
spectacle some big fireworks show that's
not how this works
this is
week after week you've heard me say this
if you listen the show ever about
um I think it was a year maybe two years
ago I started having just a weekly
breakfast with my son this year my
daughter is in second grade and I'm
gonna add her so twice a week that's a
big commitment for us financially it's a
big commitment for us time wise
especially time
um but once a week I go to lunch with my
I mean I go to breakfast with my son and
I don't miss
ever unless I'm out of town if I'm out
of town I gotta make it up and I'm gonna
add my daughter too and here's what it
is it is
lame conversation after
we play questions for humans we talk
about books that we're reading my son
and I are going to get a little more
intentional my daughter's just gonna be
building relationships and in those
moments over the course of one year two
years I've been able to say hey I made
this mistake in Middle School
and here's what it cost me
here's what it did
and you're going to be able to say hey
the single greatest decision I ever made
in my life was having you
and at 16 it was really really hard
but what your girls need more than
um somebody micromanaging every breath
and every thought
is a mom that they know and they trust
and they love is that fair
yeah
and there's probably some things you
have never told them there's probably
some things that they're not old enough
to know they're only 13 14. and you can
tell her tell these girls when you're 18
when you're 21 there's some stuff about
Mom's life I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you about the hard stuff
not because I want you to feel sorry for
me but because y'all are young women in
this crazy crazy world and I want you
all to walk into the world with eyes
wide open
and also I tell you all that to tell you
this
restriction is also super important for
14 and 13 year olds
can I tell you what I mean by that
you're gonna think I'm insane
a 14 year old girl has zero none no
business having a smartphone zero
a 14 year old girl has no business going
on dates none zero
too young they're a child
okay 14 year olds should be allowed to
go to parties where there's guys and
girls there but there's got to be adults
there and parents it's their job to call
and make sure there's adults there and
make sure there are
um there are people with the same values
that we have
and I've had hard conversations with my
kids I'm sorry this is adults between
adults but you can't go to this and I
know it's disappointing I know it's
heartbreaking
but I have one job
and so there is these move right which
is you just need to connect and let them
go let them go be them bull crap and
there's also the shut them down you
treat them like robots and that's
bullcrap too what I'm telling you Elaine
is you got to do both you got to listen
to those alarms and know they're your
alarms not everybody's
right and if you continue
um working on your own anxiety and what
does that mean I'm going to send you my
book my brand new book uh building a
non-anxious life for free it's gonna be
my gift to you okay it's not even out in
the world yet I'm gonna send it to you
okay but there's some there's a path to
take so that your alarms settle settle
down enough
so that you can then interact with the
world and identify real threats real
challenges that come up and it's not
just ringing off the hook all the time
24 7 365. uh I'm gonna tell you
something crazy last night
I just went up to my bed and I went to
sleep my wife has the flu so I'm
sleeping upstairs I just went to bed no
drugs I just turned the light off and
went to sleep can you imagine that
yeah you know
this morning I had some coffee I had to
be up here super super early for some
media I left my house at 5 15.
I just asked a cup of coffee
I'm kind of tired it was a great day can
you imagine that
I am like that's what I want for you so
bad
but I can't want it more than you want
it do you want it that bad
yeah I've actually been um working on
that honestly I'm so proud of you
and uh I actually so
um for the past two months I've made
complete changes because
um
I I trained Jujitsu and with my work
schedule it's been really just I haven't
been able to make the evening classes
like I want to so I started waking up
and going to the morning classes before
work and
um I just started my meal plan again and
everything and I've been feeling great
and so I'm like well now you know what
else do I do and I want to ask I've
asked my girls like come train with me
you know and they have this thing where
they just don't want to right now I
don't know so I'm gonna say something
that's kind of controversial okay
okay they're 13 and 14.
they have a um they get they get a vote
but not the final one
and so you can tell them you don't have
to train but you're coming to the gym
with me
and y'all gonna sit over there in the
chair but you're coming to the gym
you're not just gonna sit here my mom
goes and trains and if nothing else if
nothing else they get to watch their mom
be an absolute gangster
training early in the morning
and you get to offer it and offer it and
offer you guys want to get on that you
want to get on the match you wanna train
I'm all in
and then after six months if they don't
want to then they get to choose
something my rule with my kids is you
got to do something you can't just sit
at home and go because even the best
kids in the world are still 13 and 14
year olds and they can't compete with
the screens and the video games and the
smartphone they can't compete with all
that crap and so it's up to the parents
to say you gotta get out of the house
you got to go do one thing
and I know I also talk about the
insanity of like travel Sports and all
the lunacy like let's go uh they're not
semi-professional athletes at seven or
at 14 right so I get that too there's a
happy medium
but in many ways they don't get a vote
I mean they can say like I don't want to
do Jiu Jitsu that's fine but we're gonna
go to the gym
so you can you can participate are you
gonna sit there in that chair you're not
going to sit there on your phone either
by the way you can take a book if you'd
like you can read but that's it that's
it that's gonna happen this way and
expect pushback expect them to be 14 and
13 year olds like you and I both were
expect them to roll their eyes and be
like oh Mom's the worst you're not
you're not
the the grand picture here is this
let them know who their mom is let them
know begin to get a glimpse slowly open
the door of the next few years as to the
things mom has experienced
and continue to hold the line continue
to be a parent that has boundaries and
restrictions and takes care of their
children which is about 13 and 14 year
olds are
and if the smartphone thing isn't out of
the out of the gate already if the just
complete access to every movie channel
ever made isn't already out of the barn
take it back
take it back you're the parent
you're the parent it's both in as we
navigate this thing and if you see your
daughter getting too close to somebody
cut it off
cut it off call it out
put your daughter in safe positions okay
it's both and it's all of it this is
hard and this is messy but here's the
big the biggest of all all the pictures
here here's the biggest meta takeaway
the anxiety alarms are yours not theirs
you said something really important at
the beginning of the call that your
anxiety comes out like anger towards
them don't take the bricks out of your
backpack and hit your kids with them and
I know you don't want to
that means the work that has to be done
is work on you
continue to to see a counselor continue
to work on those things like your
physical body your nutrition continue to
do those things continue to write down
your thoughts and work hard to change
those automated things I'm gonna send
you this book work through these six
daily choices get out of debt stop owing
people money create a life where you are
free
where you're free
and then when your 14 year old comes
wandering into the room rolling her eyes
out of the back of her head you can kind
of smile
you're not gonna make me mad you're 14.
and no you're not going to this party
there's not going to be any adults and
no you're not gonna have a smartphone
because I'm I love you too much no fill
in the blank that's my job but
I'm gonna take you out let's go grab
three friends we're going to the movies
and you're gonna have capacity and space
it's Freedom it's peace and this my
sister
is changing your family tree